now people have described their whole
house shaking after a small earthquake
in South Wales overnight the European
Mediterranean seismological Center said
a 3.8 magnitude earthquake was recorded
eight miles north of the Ronda Valley in
South Wales that was just before
midnight now the British Geological
Survey that's the UK's main provider of
Quake data has not yet issued any
information but we've been getting
plenty of reaction from you people
taking to Twitter sharing their
experiences one person tweeted thought
someone was breaking into my house no
just an earthquake in South Wales
and another tweeted we've had many
earthquake Tremors before in Wales but
that Tremor shook my house to the core
in ebbw Vale
Denise got in touch with us and said she
felt the earthquake in ebbw Vale too and
her whole kitchen shook
and bli NYE gwent resident mattoshay
told Sky News his whole house shook for
about five seconds
and thanks very much for all of your
messages keep them coming in you can
tweet me directly at Sally Lockwood or
you can contact us through all the usual
means at Sky News lots of people getting
in touch thanks to Phil Jones who said
he felt the Tremor as well in Monmouth
he said the doors and windows shook
after a loud Rumble it felt like
something had grabbed the whole house
and shaken it and Fatima cook said that
near Bracken she felt her whole house
Shake as well
um but her husband slept through it well
great for him what a surprise hey I'm a
light sleeper I definitely have felt it
or we could speak more about that with
Dr John Douglas a seismologist and
Senior lecturer at strathcard University
in Glasgow thanks so much for joining us
how significant is an earthquake like
this
um you know in context
well it's it's um quite a well-known
seismic area it's
um that part of South Wales is one of
the highest seismicity areas in the UK
and such an earthquake we'd maybe expect
once every year or so so it's not that
much of a surprise or
um that surprise yeah that much of a
surprise really
so 3.8 magnitude earthquake um
considerably
um less powerful than of course the
horrendous earthquake that hit Turkey
um and Syria in recent weeks
in terms of on the Richter scale
yeah so the obviously the magnitude's
much less which translates to the amount
of energy that's released in the
earthquake
um as many million times less
um powerful than the earthquake in
turkey and Syria
um and in terms of shaking probably many
tens of times smaller shaking of the
surface also it also would have affected
a much smaller area
um only you know only felt within
perhaps
about 20 30 miles of the epicenter
now of course turkey has seen a number
of large aftershocks since that huge
earthquake that hit a couple of weeks
ago
um what is causing these earthquakes are
they more prevalent than than usual
I don't think there's really any
connection with the earthquake in turkey
and the one in Wales
um
but the earthquakes the aftershocks in
Turkey it's to do with the changes of
stress along the ports and the
neighboring thoughts and that causes
smaller earthquakes releasing that
stress
yeah so it's quite common to have
earthquakes
um aftershocks following such a large
earthquake I wouldn't expect if there is
any aftershocks after the earthquake in
Wales that them to be very very large
um generally they're much smaller
magnitudes
yeah absolutely and certainly I'm sure
there are lots of earthquakes that we
don't even feel because I was caused so
much much weaker in this in this country
Dr John Douglas thanks very much indeed
for your thoughts today thank you